volvemos para el repaso de las noticias
de economía con jorge hurtado jorge un
nuevo saludo vamos a iniciar hablando de
las reuniones de los ministros de
economía de la zona euro así es ángela y
es que 20 años después de la creación de
la moneda única europea los ministros de
finanzas de los países miembros
realizaron su última reunión del año con
un show audiovisual los ministros de
economía se mostraron optimistas sobre
las perspectivas de crecimiento
económico a pesar de la nueva variante
de coronavirus omicron y acordaron
continuar con una política fiscal
moderadamente favorable el próximo año
la nueva variante mantiene preocupados
los economistas por la posibilidad de
nuevas restricciones o confinamientos
pero el eurogrupo emitió un comunicado
donde afirma que la zona del euro se
está recuperando de la recesión más
rápido de lo que esperaban
bien y pese al optimismo de los
ministros de finanzas de europa el fondo
monetario internacional rebajó las
previsiones para la zona euro así en una
rueda de prensa la directora gerente del
fondo monetario internacional kristalina
georgieva explicó que el repunte de
casos de kobe de está llevando a un
debilitamiento de la economía de la zona
euro durante el cuarto trimestre del año
y posiblemente el primer trimestre de
2022 actualmente los datos del fbi
prevén un crecimiento del producto
interno bruto de la eurozona del 5% en
2021 y del 4,3 por ciento de 2022 aunque
el informe afirma que la zona euro se
está recuperando rápidamente gracias a
los elevados niveles de vacunación
advierte que la incertidumbre sigue
siendo alta y está vinculada a la
evolución de la pandemia el organismo
recomendó al grupo una reforma de las
normas comunitarias de control y déficit
de la deuda pública para hacerlas más
eficientes con el fin de evitar
problemas de deuda a futuro en otras
noticias este lunes el petróleo subió
tras las noticias de la variante o
microonda de coronavirus así subieron
alrededor angela de un 5 por ciento con
la esperanza de los inversores de que el
golpe está brillante no sea tan
perjudicial en sudáfrica los informes
indican que la mayoría de contagio solo
muestran síntomas leves y la casa blanca
aseguró que la prohibición de entrada al
país de extranjeros procedentes del sur
de áfrica es re considerada a diario por
los asesores de salud el crudo brent
subió 320 dólares o un 4.6 por ciento
para ubicar 60 en 73 dólares el barril
mientras que el crudo estadounidense
subió 323 dólares un 4,9 por ciento y se
situó en 69 dólares el barril y el brent
la referencia mundial ha subido este año
38 por ciento la organización de países
exportadores de petróleo y sus aliados
entre ellos rusia decidió la semana
pasada aumentar su oferta mensual en 400
mil barriles diarios para enero
y vamos a américa latina' honduras acaba
de elegir a sus nuevas autoridades están
cerca de posicionarse cuáles van a ser
los retos económicos de cara al
siguiente mandato bueno la nueva
presidenta de ese país xiomara castró de
tendencia de izquierda asumirá el mando
a partir del 27 de enero de 2022 entre
los retos que asume está en la deuda
pública un enorme déficit eléctrico el
subempleo y la pobreza en este país
centroamericano angela la deuda pública
haciendo el 60 por ciento del producto
interno bruto y ronda los 16 mil
millones de dólares constituye uno de
los principales desafíos de este nuevo
gobierno se espera que el próximo año el
país de va a pagar alrededor de 52 mil
600 millones de lempiras
esos son aproximadamente unos 2 mil 178
millones de dólares por el servicio de
auto pública lo que representa el 30 por
ciento de su presupuesto anual otro de
los grandes problemas es el déficit
financiero de la empresa nacional de
energía eléctrica que ronda los 3 mil
300 millones de dólares en honduras se
estima que el 80 por ciento que el 80
por ciento de los 95 millones de
habitantes tiene problemas de empleo y
el 75 por ciento de ellos vive en
pobreza vamos ahora a los indicadores de
la jornada arrancamos con walker que
cerró en verde dejando atrás las
pérdidas de la semana pasada al
disiparse el temor de la nueva variante
o micro en europa las acciones también
se vieron animadas por las noticias de
la nueva variante los valores turísticos
ayudaron al alza y en américa latina la
bolsa de sao paulo cerró al alza con
fuerte subida en el sector aéreo jorge
le desea una feliz noche a nuestros
televidentes sigan en france24
[Música]